mais la vice première ministre du canada
traqués et intimider lors de son passage
en alberta vendredi dernier
l'incident a été dénoncée de toutes
parts ce thème menace à notre démocratie
le débat sur la sécurité des ministres
fédéraux est relancé après la dernière
élection le ministre de la sécurité
publique avait déjà reçu le mandat
d'améliorer la protection des élus
selon nos informations l'incident
impliquant christian fui l'inde a eu
l'effet d'un électrochoc à ottawa et
l'enjeu est maintenant considéré comme
plus urgent que les options restaient
sur la table on travaille ensemble avec
l'âge et archets avec à la charge en a
sur la colline avec tous les forces
policières des propositions devraient
être soumises au conseil des ministres
au cours des prochaines semaines parmi
les scénarios à l'étude imiter
l'assemblée nationale du québec où
chaque ministre a droit un garde du
corps le coût ne devrait pas être un
obstacle croit ce député de l'opposition
officielle on est un pays jugé sérieux
pourquoi faire des économies c'en est
comme ça un service de sécurité
améliorées devrait être disponible pour
tous les élus qui en font la demande y
compris les chefs de partis selon yves
françois blanchet je crois qu'il ne faut
pas en effet qu'ils aient quelque chose
ces derniers mois les actes
d'intimidation se sont multipliées
envers les politiciens comme ces
manifestants agressifs qu'ils ont pris à
partie le chef du npd le printemps
dernier en ontario
où ces cailloux lancés au premier
ministre lors de la dernière campagne
électorale la pandémie et les
restrictions sanitaires ont exacerbé les
tensions menaces envers les politiciens
a changé affirme cet ancien garde du
corps de stephen
que la menace était contrôlé la simple
présence de gardes du corps pourrait
changer la donne croit-il je serai
présent ce quelqu'un
la personne qui mal intentionnés brille
pas à deux fois engagé en ce moment là
j'ai à ses offres de la protection à la
pièce aux élus victime de menaces jugées
sérieuses
des boutons d'alarmante aussi été
offerts aux députés en cas d'urgence si
des mesures supplémentaires s'ajoutent
certaines pourraient rester secrète pour
des raisons de sécurité ici louis blouin
radio canada ottawa